okay a lot has happened guys on day 22
week [ __ ] three infection bed
poisoning that's just [ __ ] run get the
[ __ ] away from right now we have too
many people he's s okay yeah yeah yeah
Cindy little which one is that
gotta use a toilet yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay we got to figure some [ __ ] out we
have a lot of space but we need to
continue so whoo I guess we're gonna
upgrade its gonna take hinges pipes and
everything [ __ ] I don't know if we're
[ __ ] ready for that Shannon Shannon
Shannon why you gotta be like that dude
we told you we told you what is that
Corp still there where is it
Oh [ __ ] disgusting
we proud do we have that and we do we
have
okay well she's good so i'm going to set
her up on a [ __ ] huge expedition I
said six days ago to visit and I think
it means like not not visited quipped
equipped you don't have that so you can
do that get good luck Shannon we wish
you the best in this time Joshua GAD bet
a bad John oh how does that then and and
eat something
I [ __ ] try and like upgrade it wall
and pipe yeah I don't know maybe not yep
that's good for like trading you know
shen zhui [ __ ] make more [ __ ] or
something like would cement metal let me
just make sure it doesn't get the way
the recycler okay
no I don't want to clearing this guy
scan frequencies they make yourself
useful if i upgrade this what does it do
okay [ __ ] it
what is this guy doing Andrew
and you what the [ __ ] are you doing down
there you trying to get yourself killed
what the [ __ ] Andrew scan for
frequencies wait who is that guy
hmm here's ass [ __ ] Francis that
depends what do you got take this medal
take that I don't want your [ __ ] how
much water will it take get get get get
the hell out of here and Angie I've
gotta sleep and take over scan
frequencies so Chet
exam and examine cut gut
[ __ ] get that craft back out there
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] hi [ __ ] sup we're
casting for recruits ok plastic pipe
valve transistor circuit board take 6
[ __ ]
mmm buck
wait a sec
if I break down one of these will I have
enough that is one risky [ __ ] maneuver
[ __ ] just don't have [ __ ] enough maybe I
do oh [ __ ] anyone or plastic [ __ ] this
dude do you blow it yet good good I get
the [ __ ] out there
Jesus we're [ __ ] all right CheY CheY
this [ __ ] fix this just gonna listen
did if you're not going to do nothing at
least clean the [ __ ] place I'll take
that suit
blackrain what the [ __ ]
ok
okay we're just going to search all this
[ __ ] until we [ __ ] find what we need
equipped [ __ ] yes
oh all right Shannon you're going to
have just have to take one for the team
this is a one-way mission this is a
one-way mission and I think you know
that here yep and they did a [ __ ]
make up [ __ ] how do we know you [ __ ]
what okay um broadcasts were trade yep
got a slight that's an order that's a
[ __ ] order ah yes we need lumber come
on come on come on what happened to just
like good ol what
okay Cindy Lou it's tough but you're one
of the few remaining people that can do
this job so yeah like I he's the guy
that died of radiation poisoning even
though he a [ __ ] hazmat suit on this
whole time [ __ ] why how do you want yes
huh you've so much food though yes we
actually need we need like all this
no you don't need that we do nairne
although if I to drop that what this is
getting [ __ ] that might even know she
had radiation poisoning ooh okay yes um
[ __ ] okay new plan we need some recruits
just [ __ ] broadcast non-stop for
recruits
how great if this person dies I'm gonna
[ __ ] go ballistic small house [ __ ]
ooh okay I really need this [ __ ] off
[ __ ]
yeah I because ish i had a [ __ ]
hatchet
uh [ __ ] don't need this [ __ ]
okay you're good you're good oh [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ]
mmm yeah
ok this mrs. kit Oh No
Cindy Ella you didn't broadcasting for
recruits we take we take things here
Jesus hey [ __ ] here just a bunch of [ __ ]
that's all there's
I can I come back all [ __ ] up in yo
great Jason we have a lot of hinges till
we have enough rope
hmm shet week any other two [ __ ]
you
um she attempted space we have we have a
lot of [ __ ] right now [ __ ] searching
everything else point wow there's not
like [ __ ] [ __ ] here I think we ever
check that [ __ ] I'm gonna need this [ __ ]
um this guy build some graves I had a
sleep [ __ ] would
this harvest as [ __ ]
fix can you harvest her now whoo
this guy yet good danger all right your
first order of business is [ __ ] kind
of [ __ ] no search for traders
who
she okay no she's a [ __ ] eat
something
he desperate me
this guy has to